VIVIAN CROMWELL: Welcome to the
second episode of Women
Techmakers.
So we first started Women
Techmakers around Google I/O
back in May.
It was so well-received, so
we decided to bring back a
week-long series of five amazing
and fabulous woman to
talk about their experience
in the tech industry.
So today we have a special
guest, Mary Lou Jepsen.
Before we get started, let me
quickly introduce myself.
So I head up our global Chrome
developer relations team.
So our mission is to teach
web developers how to
build great web apps.
So it has been great experience
working on the most
amazing products with the
most amazing people.
So I'm joined by Jean.
JEAN WANG: Hi, everybody.
My name is Jean Wang.
I'm a lead hardware engineer
at Google X Project Class.
And excuse me today for not
wearing my Glass device, it's
currently charging.
And I'm really excited to have
Mary Lou with us here today.
She has spearheaded a number
of display technologies,
including microdisplay, which
is actually near and dear to
our hearts at Google
X as well.
Mary Lou, would you like
to introduce yourself?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Sure.
I'm Mary Lou Jepsen.
And I just want to
correct, I think
there's 15 amazing women.
So you guys, all the amazing
hardware people at Google and
software and technology
people at Google.
So thank you for inviting me.
I'm big fans of yours.
My background, I'm the founder
and CEO of a company called
Pixel Qi, which is a spin-out
of a previous organization I
co-founded with Nicholas
Negroponte called One Laptop
per Child where I architected
the $100 laptop.
And it turns out that there was
a lot of great technology
in that laptop.
It wasn't just a cheap laptop,
so much so that the CEOs of
some of the big device makers of
the world really wanted the
low power management and screen
architectures that I
had developed for this thing,
the $100 laptop.
And so I spun out and I created
a for-profit company
called Pixel Qi where we've now
shipped about 3 million
different units across using the
excess fab capacity of the
world's LCD fabs to create
really innovative screen
architecture that's
really low power.
Before that, I founded a
microdisplay company and I was
a professor at MIT for a
while, and so forth.
JEAN WANG: Can you talk a bit
more about that evolution and
trajectory in your professional
life and how it's
gotten to where you are
today with Pixel Qi?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Ah, sure.
I really liked art and
I really liked math.
And it turned out that met with
some push from my parents
to be an electrical engineering
major because they
wanted me to be able to get
a job when I graduated.
The deal was they would help
me pay for college
if I got an EE degree.
But I found the first couple
of years of EE pretty
stifling, like if I had
any creativity it
would've crushed it.
So to sort of maintain my
sanity, I kept my art going
and got pretty much
a degree in art as
well at the same time.
And that combined itself for
me, first, in holography.
I started doing 3D things with
lasers and stuff, and
holographic video, and just
different display
technologies.
So I just really liked doing a
technically really hard puzzle
and kind of the reward is this
beautiful image at the end.
So that's what I do now.
JEAN WANG: Great.
Can you talk a bit about the
current state of the hardware
industry in terms of
the display and
where you see it going.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Yeah, it's
really interesting.
Trauma is a nice
way to put it.
I mean right now there's not
a single profitable display
manufacturer in the world.
They're running at negative
20% margin.
They have been for a
number of years.
I think Sharp just forecasted
they're going to lose $6
billion, Panasonic worse,
nearly $10 billion.
Negative 20% margin
for a number of
years is hard to maintain.
It's actually geopolitical.
China's building up more
manufacturing capacity and
there's just excess capacity.
So there's that.
And then in the device space,
Apple and Samsung have
executed very, very well,
as I think, duh,
everybody knows that.
What maybe doesn't sort of
make the stage as sort of
pronounced is that everybody
else, HP, Dell, Nokia, RIM,
Asus, Acer are running at nearly
just about break-even.
And a lot of R and D
has been slashed.
And so, there is just very
few innovative--
you're doing one of the most
innovative hardware programs
on the planet yourself--
but there's just very, very
little of that today.
I think Andreessen says software
eats the world.
That's great, but it still has
to run on something, and
there's still this device.
And if it's all Apple something,
god help us because
they're going to control the
whole stream of data.
We need, I think, more
diversity, and we're
searching for that.
I like Apple products,
I like all of them.
But I just think it's more
interesting if there was more
than just two companies
shipping
devices in huge volumes.
JEAN WANG: So how is Pixel Qi
and how are you doing your
part to try to make the display
industry profitable?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Well, even when
I designed this thing,
the reason I created a new
screen was cost, but it was
also power.
In the developing world,
kids don't have power
outlets in the wall.
Or if they do, they're
not on all the time.
So this is a 1 watt laptop.
The next laptop up is
about 10 watts.
And that comes from a lot
of the power management
architecture that we created.
So what are we doing is
continuing that march down in
a world where, since I made
this, the power consumption of
screens has quadrupled in the
last three to four years.
This is in a world where Intel
will respin a chip to save 10
milliwatts, Qualcomm will fight
about microwatts, and
the screen power consumption
has gone up like 5 watts.
If you look at like an iPad 3,
Apple's, sort of one of their
flagship products, it's a 9 watt
machine, 8 watts of that
is taken by the screen.
So what we figured out how to do
is how to basically take 7
watts out of that, not 7
milliwatts, not 7 microwatts,
7 watts, while maintaining the
front-of-screen performance,
including the resolution and so
forth, viewing angle, color
saturation, contrast,
and all of that.
So that's our next generation
architecture.
But we've done that by building
up starting with this
screen in here that's sunlight
readable and really working on
basically what I call small
aperture pixels.
As you increase the screen
resolution, if the transistor
stays the same size, it
takes up more and more
of the pixel area.
That means the light from the
backlight gets blocked and
can't get through.
And so you've got to crank up
that backlight and you've got
to power all those
extra pixels.
Power is a huge deal.
Maybe it's not even power,
it's thermal management.
It's what do you do
with the heat.
You can use the best batteries
you want, but even still the
iPad 3 is overheating.
There's the thermal budget.
And so if the pixels are
getting smaller and the
transistors stay the same size
and you crank it up, all that
power goes to the screen
rather than a zippier
processor, multitasking, being
able to beam video around,
being able to beam video to the
Google Glass, whatever.
You can use power for a lot of
different things if the screen
isn't hogging it.
So we're working on
that problem.
And what we've done is over the
last eight years increased
the front-of-screen
performance.
So now we can match that of
OLED, or any of the Android
screens, or Motorola.
I don't mean to just pick on
Apple, but at a competitive
screen performance, including
the contrast, color, viewing
angle, resolution,
and so forth.
So that's what we've
been doing.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: Is One Laptop
per Child, the laptop, it's
also [? convenient ?] to improve
the screen display?
Because I know I read
recently they also
started having tablets.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Yes, so
we're designing the
screen for the tablet.
And we have improved
the front-of-screen
performance of this.
Oh, I just turned it off.
I'll turn it back on.
But you can see, and I brought
a big flashlight to show you.
But yeah, so One Laptop per
Child, I developed the screen
for it and we continue
to support them.
When I created Pixel Qi, it was
a spin-off from a hardware
charity, a nonprofit.
And so we did a cross-licensing
deal where we
get the IP and all the patent
stuff from One Laptop per
Child to use, to continue to
develop, and we give them
access to all of our IP that
we invent forever for their
nonprofit humanitarian goals.
So we still support them also
with finding vendors and
things especially in Asia.
I spend most of my
time in Asia.
JEAN WANG: It's really
impressive
about the power savings.
Can you talk about that
discovery process and how you
invent these new architectures
to achieve the savings?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Ah, yeah,
how did it invent?
If you think of this, I've
got it back up and I
can show you that.
Actually, I've got
a big flashlight.
This is the brightest flashlight
on the planet that
you can carry on a plane.
And so you can see it's
sunlight readable.
And so it came from sort
of thinking about
really wanting E Ink.
And that's like compared to my
supposedly sunlight readable
Nokia Lumia phone.
This one, how do you invent in
general is you throw a lot of
ideas and see what sticks, I
think, and work through.
And I just think about
it all the time.
I can't sleep, I wake up.
In this case, the kids had to
get their laptops, how are you
going to solve it?
Oh my gosh.
It was like falling in love
almost, complete with not
being able to sleep past 3:00
in the morning and waking up
and thinking, how am I going
to do it, how do we do it?
But the progression of this
screen to our next screens and
our next screens came from sort
of a point of discovery.
We figured out how to make a
really good small aperture
screen because we wanted to
use most of the pixel to
reflect the light.
Like why fight the sun,
why not use it?
So we developed an architecture
where we could
hide a lot of circuitry
underneath those mirrors.
We got rid of one layer in the
top substrate and added a
layer to the bottom substrate.
And it wasn't obvious to me that
that could make a large
difference in where other screen
technology was going.
But we've actually created a
lot of different IP around
that idea to solve a lot of our
customers' problems and a
lot of the problems that
we want to solve as
we invent new screens.
I guess I'm not really answering
the question though.
Like how do you invent?
I don't know.
I just like noodling
on problems.
JEAN WANG: I think some of it's,
of course, you do it off
on your own when you're
sleeping, perhaps dreaming
about it, or just having
lunch by yourself.
And oftentimes, you just have
brainstorms with people that
you work with and from
diverse perspectives.
So optics team, plus the product
design team, plus the
EE team getting together in one
room with manufacturing
and just figuring out what are
the key issues that we have
currently and what can we
do to attack it from a
perspective we never
thought of before.
So there is some of that.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: I also like
the hard criticism.
I find out more about that when
people tell me the things
they don't like about what I
did, how come you didn't,
especially if it's
something new.
And sometimes they will tell
you that to your face.
You know, Vinod Khosla has said
his Twitter stream is
very valuable for finding
out what people
really think about him.
They'll post it in blogs and
different things sometimes.
Because it's just grown so
much, every little nit,
people, you have fanboys too
even for Pixel Qi, and they
say what they like and what
they're frustrated with.
And when I hear their
frustrations, I think, huh,
how can we fix that or the
intersection of things.
But yeah, sometimes I just dream
about it, and wake up,
and it's solved, yes.
JEAN WANG: It's a nice case.
It [INAUDIBLE] happens
all the time.
So all these things are great
advantages for technology, are
there any disadvantages that
you can share with us?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Disadvantages,
I suppose, for
me, the big sacrifices I've made
are just basically living
on a plane and giving
up having a life.
When you start a company, when
we started One Laptop per
Child, forget about kind of
friends, family, all of that.
So those are the sacrifices that
it seems to take because
you have to work on other
people's schedules.
And the time zone thing is so
great and the travel time is
so great that it's pretty hard
to figure out when the factory
is going to be down in advance,
because you have to
be there immediately if
there's an issue.
I suppose disadvantages of our
technology, today we've sort
of started with lower
front-of-screen performance on
some level, although
it's more readable.
Which should matter because
books may disappear, but
reading is not probably going
to disappear any time soon.
But Apple communicates with
its customers very well.
So whatever Apple says matters,
that's what matters.
Didn't used to be important to
be able to read a screen like
that, but now it is because
Apple said it was.
So we all have to do that.
I'm really grateful that Apple,
a lot of us in the
display community and hardware
community for a long time
wanted higher resolution.
And I always spent the $500
extra to buy something with
high resolution.
But now Apple has communicated
effectively to its customers
that resolution matters,
so everybody
knows resolution matters.
So it's a world where a single
company calls the shots.
And the entire industry has
slashed its R and D for the
past few years and is living
at negative 20% margin.
So it's interesting to work
inside of that because we
started during the
economic crisis.
So we've developed some pretty
interesting R and D. You guys
clearly have there.
But there just aren't that
many efforts like that.
You see the big software
players, Microsoft coming out
with hardware, Amazon, Android,
Facebook entering
because they're frustrated.
They can't just continue to let
Apple eat their breakfast,
lunch, and dinner.
Dell, HP, Nokia they all
misstepped or Apple executed
well, but it doesn't matter.
You see people filling
in for that.
But it's been walking
through the
valley of death or something.
It feels a lot like that through
this period of time.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: What is
your take on Amazon?
Do you think they're doing
pretty well in
terms of those devices?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Yeah, I mean
there's an example where
screen technology
really mattered.
Sony took on E-ink first, but
didn't get the content.
Sony, of all people, couldn't
get the content.
But Amazon got the content and
was able to create, really
spur, catalyze, execute on the
e-book reader, the e-reader
revolution five years ago now.
And now it's come out
with other things.
They're building
out more space.
There's something like
1,200 people working
on different things.
And there's a lot of rumors that
they're coming out with
other sets of devices.
They've certainly been hiring.
It's exciting, I think.
It's very exciting.
What does Eric Schmidt call
it, the Gang of Four.
I don't think that you guys
actually gang together though,
it's sort of more competition
of four
giant companies really.
It seems to be the current
landscape.
And I don't know, what's
your view?
VIVIAN CROMWELL: I'm more on
the software side of the
[? scene. ?]
So it's just like a lot of
continuous innovation.
I mean, for us, like Chrome, we
have Chromebooks and so on,
just like filling a market where
people, in addition to
meeting the [? tablets, ?]
which is always on the go, or
having a laptop being able to
do development or other
kinds of tasks.
Like I found a place in my
kitchen, I use my Chromebook
when I'm doing the cooking.
So I'm finding the places for
all these different devices.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: And can
you spill on it?
That's OK.
Yeah, for cooking it's been a
dream for a long time that
always failed, was the
cooking menu device.
So maybe this is it.
But it's an issue.
JEAN WANG: Well hopefully
with Glass you can
use Glass for cooking.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: We're looking
at a world in 2020 where the
estimates are there will be
10 devices per person.
And so the charging gets
to be an issue
because all of the adapters.
And sure, there's the inductive
charging, but that's
not very efficient.
And it'd be nicer, I think, the
reason I work so hard is I
believe we have to get a world
of self-powered devices.
Where you have to lower, just
like Intel does, or Qualcomm,
or any chip maker, in the screen
and everything, the
power is so low so that it
becomes like a calculator, a
small little solar
cell is enough to
power the whole thing.
And I think that we
can get there.
Solar cells have gotten
a lot better.
But the screen power consumption
now takes 90% of
the battery.
It's only a small exaggeration
to say the battery in a device
is there to power the screen.
And so, I think that that
will open up what
we can do with things.
But take it further, why can't
we exhale the device, or spray
paint it on the wall and peel
it off and eat it, or
whatever, tattoo it
on our bodies.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: A watch.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Certainly
the health care
devices that will come.
There's some merger of
mind and device.
You're right there on
the head, I'm sure.
You probably can't
talk about it.
JEAN WANG: Yeah, power is a
definite concern for Glass.
And to be able to use the device
all day is something
that we think seriously about.
And so anything we could to do
to reduce the power from the
display point of view, or even
the electronics, the audio
system that we have, all
of that is extremely
important to work on.
And we're always on the lookout,
not just as a big
company, but looking at small
companies and innovations
there for technology
improvement, for battery
technology, and electronics.
What is the [INAUDIBLE] thing
we can do to achieve a great
user experience?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Right.
And the battery technology
is getting better
at about 10% a year.
Maybe there's some breakthrough
stuff.
There's some very interesting
companies.
And that's good.
But also there's the
charge time.
And so if the device takes more
power because it's got a
better innovative battery,
there's still the charge time
to the battery.
And it's great because we can
use our mini USB adapters on
most things, but that really
limits the charge time.
It's only 5 volts.
And so it takes six,
seven hours to
charge a typical tablet.
In fact, the Motorola Xoom
tablet charges faster, which
is why OLPC used it for a
deployment in Ethiopia,
because it's got a 12 volt
special adapter so it can
charge twice as fast.
Can we just make it so that
they can self power?
If you're walking around, why
isn't that enough to charge it
or a little bit of light?
Can we get it down
to that low?
And I think it's certainly
possible.
It's very key in a lot of the
developing world where there
isn't steady ready access
to electricity.
You could say, well,
that will change.
Infrastructure will be developed
if you wait 10
years, 20 years.
But some places it's hard to go
there and actually believe
that everybody will have ready
access to electricity.
Because then you actually have
to think about the global
warming issues and sort of how
much of our electronics are
now the footprint of
our energy usage.
In homes it used to be it was
the refrigerator that was the
most power hungry thing,
now it's the TV.
And it's 10% of the power use
in a home is electronics.
And as we get more electronics,
that goes up.
So there's this whole green
level to it, which people
don't think of in the first
level because you're focused
on transportation being
one of the key things.
But it's also just more
convenient if you don't have
to power this stuff up.
So consumers can vote.
But there's certainly places
where we're not really able to
compete with Apple or Samsung.
If they only spent 10 times
what we did, we could.
But they spend 1,000
times what we do.
They spend billions and
we spend millions.
So we actually have a nice
niche in our company.
We serve 130 million people that
can't buy normal products
from Apple, Samsung,
or other vendors
because they work outside.
Construction workers, military,
cops, meter maids,
truck drivers, they
all need stuff.
So we have stuff like this.
It's kind of a brick.
But you can throw it on the
ground and it works or
whatever, spill on it.
And it's fine.
But you can dunk and
different things.
It says activate Windows now.
And it's sunlight readable.
I can even stand on it
if you want to see.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: What is the
special usage of this device?
Is it for the truck driver?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Actually,
this is a new
product from Trimble.
And they actually have
the surveyors of the
world, which are huge.
They've got like 73%
of that market.
So it's actually data input.
There's even this in the back.
But, yeah, I mean you can use it
for anything that you need
to be outside.
If it's getting mud on it, if
someone will roll over it, you
need the ruggedness.
And you need to be able
to see it outside
for it to be useful.
The truth is, if we all
stayed inside all the
time, it would be OK.
But in reality, people
go outside.
Most of us go outside
every day.
We use our cell phones
outside.
We use digital cameras
You can't even tell if your
grandmother is smiling when
you take a picture of her--
she may not be around that
much longer--
with all of today's devices
because you
can't see them outside.
So we're doing specialty
stuff for professional
photographers.
But we believe that people
will care about that, and
power, and readability.
It's difficult in an
industry that is
struggling like it is now.
So we persevere and we're pretty
happy about having this
large niche.
We go profitable
on this niche.
But our big ambition is to
make innovative screens.
In the year 2000 maybe, let's
call it 10 million laptops
shipped that year.
There were tablets
that shipped.
Apple didn't invent
the tablet.
But it's much smaller numbers.
And so the volume that you
needed to achieve on a new
product was relatively small.
Fast forward to today where
you've got 250 million, 300
million laptops, same amount
of desktops, 1
billion cell phones.
When you start mass production,
you have to be
able to go to a million
units a month.
That means you have to
use existing factory
infrastructure or build your
own factory, which costs a
couple billion dollars.
If you spend a couple billion
dollars to build a factory,
you've got to amortize that over
the output for, whatever,
five years.
That's what Qualcomm did.
They were basically wrapping a
$100 to $500 bill around every
product they shipped as a
gift to the customer.
And so what we noticed is that
it's a moment, it seems to be,
in the display industry where
it's a lot like 25 years ago
in silicon where there were all
these different types of
silicon processes.
There was CMOS, which
won, silicon on
sapphire, gallium arsenide.
And CMOS got good enough, it
wasn't the best, but it got
good enough and the processes
reliable enough where more of
those factories were made.
And people could basically
design a chip in software and
send the file to the
manufacturer
and back came a chip.
So we think it's that moment
in the display industry.
We're the only fabless LCD
company in the world.
We're the only external team
that's ever gotten-- they
still call it tape out, that's
how old the nomenclature is,
back when you had computer
tapes-- that has gotten to
tape out into the big factories
of the world.
Not even Apple gets that and
they get everything, for good
reason mind you.
But we've been doing that and
basically using as-is the
factory process, Windows
processes, the materials that
are allowed in the fab, and
re-architecting every single
layer, the liquid crystal, how
we drive it, how we create
structures.
Because basically we're
playing with layers
of metal and oxide.
Oxide, another word for
that's glass, right?
And metal is a conductor and
oxide is an insulator, but
metal is also a reflector.
And oxide is, well, glasses
are made out,
there's lenses, right?
And so you have to think of
shapes that can be both a
transistor shape or a line shape
and have good electron
mobility, while playing a double
role to bounce the
light where you want the light
to go and in the way that you
want it to go.
And it's pretty fun.
It's a very analog process.
We work a lot on like
a small pixel, a 100
micron square pixel.
Then we make millions of them.
We copy it when we
nail that pixel.
And that's really what we are
trying to do in a world where
97% of all screens are liquid
crystal displays using thin
film transistors.
There are some other movements
in the industry.
You're leading a fantastic one,
love LCOS or any of the
microdisplay technologies.
That's single crystal silicon
and you can do so much more in
the backplane.
And that's actually where
we came from.
A lot of the people in the
company I have now I started
working with in the mid '90s
when we started microdisplays.
And there was a big microdisplay
effort.
It was thought that
that was going to
beat direct-view HDTV.
We lost, LCD won.
But we were developing
incredible innovation in the
backplane because we had single
crystal silicon, we
could tape it out to those CMOS
fabs, back would come the
chip, and we could smear the
liquid crystals on them.
I had a factory in Richmond,
California with high school
kids working in it where we'd
actually crank out 20,000
units a month or so into
head-mounted displays, and
wristwatch video, and stuff
like that in the '90s.
Unfortunately, nobody bought the
head-mounted displays, so
we pivoted to HDTV and lost.
But what happened was there was
this sensibility that was
developed of architecture,
I think, more from that
background than the people,
primarily in Asia, who figured
out how to do high volume,
low cost manufacturing.
Basically hang a big picture
window TV on the wall.
That was a dream for 20 years.
It now costs $200 to
make a 42 inch TV.
So given that that's the factory
infrastructure that we
have, how do we use it to do
something more interesting?
Not everything has to just
be a little TV, right?
We need screens.
The world's information is
digital, the way we access
that information is through
the screen.
And that's why I'm quite
fascinated by the work that
you're doing.
What can that be?
And I think part of it is you
can't even get there until you
solve the power problem because
as you make these
better screens the power just
goes through the roof.
Long answer, sorry.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: I have a
slightly unrelated question.
I'm just kind of curious.
I noticed the company
name is Pixel Qi.
And I'm Chinese so I
can read Chinese.
So I realize that Qi actually
means air in Chinese.
I'm kind of wondering if there's
any special story
behind the name of
the company.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Yeah, sure.
Basically I've spent a lot of
time doing hardware as has
been well publicized,
it's Election
Day, through the election.
We lost our manufacturing
infrastructure in the West.
It's moved to Asia.
So if you do hardware, I
spend a lot of time.
And people, when I visit a
company, they'll give me the
English name of the company and
the English address, which
is completely useless.
Pick your country, it's
completely useless in Japan,
Korea, Taiwan, China.
I learned some.
I'm not as good as you, but
I've learned some Chinese.
And I like the idea
of the display is
really what's alive.
It's the Confucius belief that
sort of panned most of Asia of
a life force in an
inanimate object.
Because the screens
are kind of alive.
And then also I just wanted to
a company name that was the
same in every language.
Qi is called chi in Japanese
and kwi in Taiwanese.
But the symbol is the same,
which is steam rising over
rice, right?
The idea that rice is kind of
alive, it's got steam in it.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: We also kind of
have a meaning like air is
sort of very fundamental to
everything so you're kind of
using the natural resources.
That's my using interpretation
of the story.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Also, I learned
later that it also
means something in kung fu,
kind of like an anger.
And I thought, oh no,
we called the
company the angry pixel.
Maybe that would be OK.
But people say it's OK.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: That's
very neat.
JEAN WANG: Yeah, it's great.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: And the
website was available.
JEAN WANG: So you have this
great combination of
technologies expertise as well
as business acumen and skills.
Can you talk a bit more about
the business side of things,
and how you've been able to
establish manufacturing
capability by working with these
Taiwanese manufacturers,
and how that was established and
how you continued to grow.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Yeah,
that was really hard.
What makes me a little bit
jealous of software is
software people don't have
to get permission.
And in order with these
factories and get these
resources, you have
to get permission.
So you have to learn how
And I'm a woman in Asia.
Like basically, they
remember me.
They think whatever I'm saying
is a joke, it'll never work.
It used to be for the $100
laptop, they just thought it
was so funny, they would take
the meeting because it was the
humor portion of their day.
The CEO of Samsung flanked by
four VPs on one side and four
VPs on the other side and little
old me on the other
side of the room explaining
my new architecture
and the $100 laptop.
And they just thought
it was so funny.
And they'd point out all the
reasons it wouldn't work.
And then I realized, ha, this is
great, they're helping with
the design.
So I'd write all these
things down.
I'd say, we've got some answers
on these, but these
ones, they're really
good points.
So thank you for helping, and
if we can get answers that
hold water here, can I come back
to you in a few months?
And they'd say, sure.
And I realized that by doing
that, they actually really
wanted to help.
With the $100 laptop the cause
was worthy, transform poor
kids in the developing
world, everybody's
pretty much for that.
Particularly a lot of the
executives in Asia who many of
them grew up poor and how
computing changed their lives
and believe deeply and
profoundly in how it can
change other people's lives.
I worked in Asia for a long
time, but through that project
I was the co-founder,
I was leading.
Rather than building a factory
in California, I was leading,
trying to get their resources,
and was finally able to.
And they remember me, they
underestimate me, but then
when you go back, they say, oh
yeah, you're the one I thought
was a nut last time, what are
you're doing this time?
It's probably fun too
and a little nutty.
And so you go with that and
you just try to put this
incredible solid structure under
this thing that looks
like a nutty idea.
Because even in cultures where
they say, whatever, Japan, the
nail that sticks up gets
hammered down is an
expression, they still like
to break the rules.
They do.
Everybody wants to do,
in technology,
like the next thing.
And if you have to develop
that solid structure
underneath.
The reason I lived there, I
spent so much of my time there
is during this crisis I started
Pixel Qi in 2008.
I got my first term sheet the
week Lehman Brothers went out
of business.
The VC that gave it to
us didn't execute
on that term sheet.
It's been hard, and so things
are changing fast and furious.
Our first manufacturer
went bankrupt,
got bought by Foxconn.
It was really quite difficult.
There's been a huge price
fixing scandal.
A lot of the executives in
the display industry
have gone to jail.
Or when they travel to the US,
the CEO of AUO wasn't allowed
to leave for a year and a half
because he was under
indictment and there was
no extradition treaty.
Anyway, he was found innocent
after all of that.
But there's all these
things going on.
And I'm American and Wall
Street's my problem, the
extradition treaty, like it's my
fault they say, because I'm
American, I should fix it.
And I just realized that I have
to be there a lot of the
time to talk them through,
explain Wall
Street wasn't my fault.
I'm sorry I'm American, and we
really shouldn't have done
that, and those guys
on Wall Street, and
women on Wall Street.
But I just think everything's
changing for them.
I'm dealing with executives
that are losing $2 million
every hour.
Why are they talking to me?
Why?
What am I going to
do for them?
It's like well, you've already
eaten all of your children.
There's no more children
left to eat.
They've killed their R&D.
I offer them a cheap form of
R&D that really works.
We've shipped 3 million
screens.
It might sound crazy, but here's
why these will work.
Give me over to your CTO, I'll
prove out some of it, but
we're not going to tell you all
the IP so you're going to
have to trust us.
We'll show you a demo of
a proof of concept or
something like that.
And that's how I get them to
continue to work with us.
But the deals are always
changing because the pressures
are so great on those executives
right now.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: So since you
have worked so many years in
Asia, we are also engineers in
the tech industry, I'm kind of
curious to know like when you're
doing business in Asia,
do you notice any cultural
differences between doing
business in Silicon Valley
versus Asia?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Yeah,
so different.
Even for different countries,
they're all so different.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: Is it
a lot more difficult?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: It's
just different.
And when I context switch back
to California, you're supposed
to have kind of, well, in
Taiwan they'd call it
arrogant, everybody
in California.
But it's not called that here
because everybody's sort of
more direct, is another
way to describe it.
Although you just need to
understand and context switch
between the different cultures
so that you don't come off as
a wallflower to not
direct enough.
And sometimes I have trouble.
Especially when I hadn't spent
much time in California for
like three years, and this year
I've spent more time, on
the West Coast more than
just California.
I got more up to date, but like
when I first came back I
was a bit more nuanced
rather than direct.
And that's really considered
quite arrogant with people
that I deal with in
China and Taiwan.
I think Korea is more direct.
I think Japan, it's so
different, especially
post-Tsunami.
They're all different.
And I guess in One Laptop per
Child, every country that we
went into, it's in over 50
countries, you have to sort of
figure out what works and
what doesn't work.
Hopefully not using the trial
and error method, but having
somebody that understands sort
of what you're thinking and
sort of can sit down and tell
you three levels down kind of
a map for it.
When I first started living in
Asia, I must have offended so
many people.
I was walking into walls.
I didn't even know
they were walls.
I didn't know that I was making
people angry with me.
I didn't know that.
And I tried to get
forgiveness.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: So Mary Lou,
when you grew up, what are
some of the women role
models for you?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Well, my mom
who really encouraged me.
And I think actually
a VP at Google.
I met her when I started at
MIT for grad school, Megan
Smith became my best friend.
And Margaret Minksy, Marvin
Minsky's daughter and Megan
Smith shared an office.
And Megan was just this
force of nature.
That first year they made a
video of her for the Lego Logo
people that became Mindstorms
called Megan in Motion.
And she was just so high
energy, and just doing
everything, and let's do it.
When?
How about now?
And so we'd sleep every other
day at that time.
It just opened my eyes.
I never really thought
about traveling.
I just really liked
holography.
So I was sort of niche,
I guess, then.
And she kind of blew the
doors off of that.
When I focused on holography,
what was really interesting is
it was about half men
and half women in
holography at that time.
A lot of the women tended to be
artists, a lot of the men
tended to be techy, but there
was cross between both.
And a woman, Paula Dawson, who's
a holographic artist in
Australia, I went
and collaborated
with her for a while.
And I used to teach history
of science.
And there's all these amazing
women if you look back that
aren't fully recognized, but
really did amazing things.
And one that I really like is
Lucia Galvani, who was the
wife of Lucio Galvani, who
discovered basically a new
kind of electricity
in about 1790.
She actually observed.
He was dissecting frogs and they
were outside and there
was electrical sparks.
It was either a generator, they
thought there were these
different types of electricity
then, there
were like five different.
Ben Franklin discovered
one, the key.
But anyway, the frog's
legs moved.
And that meant electricity was
causing our muscles to move
inside of us.
It inspired "Frankenstein,"
Mary Shelley that wrote
"Frankenstein." But she made the
observation according to
the history and doesn't
really get credit.
Galvanism, galvanic, all of that
comes from the Galvanis.
And I think there's tons of
women through history that
just never got the credit
for what they did.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: So you believe
women should really
fight for the credit for the
work they're doing to be able
to gain the recognition
in the office?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: It's
interesting because the way
you do that in Asia versus
here is different.
But I think it's very critical
to find a way to get credit
for the work.
And the way I do that, I don't
know, you can talk to how you
do it, I used to not do it.
I didn't know how to do it.
And then I realized, wow, I'm
just really excited when
somebody gets something pretty
cool to work, and I tell
everybody about how
cool it is.
And then I just realized I
should also say, I got this
work, isn't it great?
I'm awesome.
And then and tell the other
people like there's all these
great things going on.
And so I found it a lot easier
to take credit, also part of
it is sort of becoming
a boss and learning
how to do all that.
But in my early years, I didn't
actually quite know how
to do that.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: Are there a
lot of female engineers in
your organizations?
Do you do anything trying
to encourage
more females to enter?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: We do.
We do have a lot of women
in our company.
In fact, our VP of
manufacturing,
Belle Fu, is amazing.
She brought up four
different fabs in
three different companies.
She was a chemist by training
and then she went and got a
Ph.D. in psychology because
the decisions taken didn't
actually make any
technical sense.
So she runs all of our
fab relations.
And it's really great because
we have to understand the
space the decision makers and
decision influences are in,
because we are not their
top priority.
We're just always at that sort
of are we in the fab or out of
fab because we're so
small and whatnot.
So that's really key.
And we have other
women as well.
And would like more,
certainly.
The numbers are pretty daunting,
I think, across the
technical industries.
It's depressing.
JEAN WANG: So what sort of
advice would you give to be
able to rise into leadership
roles and to excel in their
careers and development?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Advice,
it depends.
I think, in one sentence,
is do the hard stuff.
Do the hard stuff, learn
it, even if it's hard.
And also stay passionate about
something, see if you can
combine them, like whatever
the field is.
Because if you don't understand
deeply how some of
this stuff works, like
especially the stuff that
maybe you don't like.
Like I didn't like
some aspects.
I hated inclined planes.
I just hated it.
I thought it was just a dumb.
I grew up on a farm, I never saw
once something go down at
that force on an inclined
plane, it
doesn't actually happen.
I just thought the whole thing
was dumb and I had to do that
for like a year for engineering
school.
But it just seemed like I had to
stick through it to get to
the other side.
It's really just Newton's Law
and you've got to learn that.
But different people have
barriers at different times.
And I think, basically, if you
can do that, I've mastered a
lot of different fields because
I loved holography and
you couldn't actually get
a degree in holography.
So I had to learn vision
science, and chemistry, and
physics, and math, and art,
mechanics, and a lot of
different things in order to
learn, how to program, and a
lot of different things so that
I could make really good
whole holograms.
And then you realize that it's
OK, you can sort of catch up
quick in a field.
And part of that is you have to
deal with, as a girl, like
they're all boys.
And there's this thing, like
at MIT, people call people
that don't know everything
like brain-dead.
And I remember joining the
holography group at MIT.
There was actually a
holography group.
And everybody kept talking
in these sort
of weird coded terms.
And there was a hologram that
was made and was called
[? sanjigen. ?]
And I didn't know what
[? sanjigen ?]
meant in Japanese because
it was a Japanese word.
It means 3D.
And it just happened to be the
name of something and somehow
I was supposed to know
what that meant.
And there were so many levels
in figuring out what the
context words, where if you
could just get through that,
it's like hazing.
It just feels like they don't
really write it down and you
just have to figure out
a way through that.
And some people will help you
eventually, as long as you
sort of help them, I guess.
And I think that part
is pretty hard.
Because the assumption is that
when you're coming in,
especially as a younger woman,
or maybe it wasn't the
assumption, maybe I just
felt it was that.
The impostor syndrome thing is
that you must be an idiot
because you don't know
this stuff already.
Like how on Earth was I supposed
to know the type of
hologram that was called
[? sanjigen ?]
was like this type of hologram
made this way.
It's like impossible, right?
Do you guys have
maybe similar?
JEAN WANG: Yeah, so I guess I've
been pretty lucky in a
way, despite going to an
engineering school.
At Caltech the ratio is 3:1 for
engineering and even worse
for EE, which was what
my degree was in.
But after a while, at least
for me personally, I just
didn't even notice.
We were all just people trying
to get our degree, trying to
get our A's or whatnot,
and doing research.
And you don't really notice it
until somebody actually points
it out to you.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: That's
interesting.
JEAN WANG: I think that's
been an evolution.
And of course, we're standing
on the shoulders of all the
women who have gone before us.
And it will continue
to improve.
But I think it's turning out to
be less of an issue now as
it was in the past.
And I hope it continues
to improve.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: I only noticed
that I was a woman
when I was in the
younger years.
But I used to lifeguard at the
beach in summers before I got
my engineering jobs
in the summers.
And I remember they'd all tell
me like they would never work
for a woman, all the lifeguards
who were my
colleagues on the beach.
And that was sort of what
they would say then.
I just stopped noticing.
And I'm me, and it's their
problem, and it's [INAUDIBLE]
more difficult.
But then, that said, Middle
East is a different story.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: I kind of
feel like I grew up in a
pretty lucky environment because
my family is pretty
heavily engineering oriented.
My dad is a physics and
optical engineer.
My mom is a mechanical
engineer.
So as I grew up, I never really
realized there is a
gender association to what
you can do and not.
I think the first time I
actually realized that was
probably after I graduated
from school.
Because in all the companies
I applied for, they were
actually putting a ratio of how
many males they want to
hire, how many females.
So that kind of struck me.
Oh wow, they're actually
putting gender with the
position you want to fill.
So in general, pretty lucky like
in terms of growing up in
a very supportive environment.
JEAN WANG: So now it's time for
our live question portion
of the session.
First question comes from
T.S. In California.
She asks, or he asks, it's not
clear, with the future usage
trend going into mobile
computing with smaller devices
like tablet, should
OLPC become One
Tablet per Child instead?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Well,
they're doing that.
The laptops and the keyboards
are pretty useful.
They've put touchscreen into
the latest version of this,
which uses the same thing.
And this thing actually
does turn around.
It's big, it's bulky,
it's like a brick.
Oh, sorry.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: Is this the
same, like $100 per tablet, or
it's going to be a little
bit higher?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Probably
less, I think $75.
They demoed it at CES last
year or year before.
It got a lot of Best
of CES things.
But the question is when it
goes into production.
OLPC has done a very interesting
experiment of
actually airdropping tablets.
And they use the Motorola Xooms
because they charge fast
rather than starting a
pre-production run.
They only have a small number.
They airdropped them into two
illiterate villages in Kenya
about eight months ago to see
what would happen, places that
there's no written languages,
nobody knows how to read.
The adults, no language,
writing is used.
And they wanted to see if the
kids would learn how to read
or what would happen.
In one village just the
kids used them.
And in another village,
the kids and the
adults used them together.
But the kids have learned a lot
of pre-reading stuff, a
lot of alphabet.
The government decided primary
education in--
Sorry, it's not.
Kenya, it's Ethiopia--
primary education in Ethiopia
is an Amharic, but secondary
and tertiary is in English.
And so they thought, let's
put English on it.
In fact, sidebar, we
made the first
Amharic keyboard in OLPC.
Nobody had ever made
one before.
There was a lot of firsts
that we did.
But tablets in the villages,
the kids started to
learn how to read.
They also learned how
to hack them.
Because OLPC had turned off the
camera features because
they wore down the battery
really quickly.
And the kids figured out how
to hack around and hack
Android to turn on the camera.
So that was great.
But yeah, so tablets are very
important going forward.
But different countries
are picking.
Every child in Uruguay
has one of these.
The Uruguayan government has
ordered another 100,000.
About half the kids in Peru,
50 other countries, 26
different languages.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: So are those
mainly being distributed
through the local government?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Through the
ministry of education, they
buy them en masse like textbooks
and then give them
out to the kids and they have
a lifetime of five years.
And they could be with
tablets as well.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: I'm wondering,
it seems that even
outside the developing countries
there are a lot of
other places kids can use
laptops like this, but I
haven't really seen a lot of
massive adoption of these
laptops outside the developing
countries.
I'm just kind of curious why.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: I remember when
OLPC started, we had our
first prototypes out.
And the mayor of Birmingham,
Alabama walked into our office
on day in Cambridge,
across from MIT.
And he said, do what you
want, arrest me.
He was a big guy.
And he said, arrest me, do
what have to have to, I'm
leaving here with two laptops.
Call the cops, don't care.
Because he wanted some for the
kids of Birmingham, Alabama.
He got them, we gave him
some laptops, some
of the other schools.
But we really designed this one,
it's mesh networked so
you don't need a Wi-Fi
connection, all the laptops
talk to each other.
We actually had to finish the
standard for 802.11s.
S stands for mesh because
M was gone.
But it's really a super low
power, sunlight readable,
rugged laptop for kids that we
specifically designed for the
developing world.
Even there's like extra screws
underneath the keyboard in
case the kids have to fix the
screws and they can fix,
sorry, the laptop, and the
screws drop on the ground and
they can't have it.
There's a lot of solutions.
I mean Chromebook might
be a good solution.
You guys are at $250
right now, right?
That's pretty good.
So there's a lot of different
solutions that exist now.
When we started this thing eight
years ago, people really
thought we were nuts.
What Steve Jobs said, what Craig
Barrett said, what Bill
Gates, I mean they
were shocking.
They were insulting,
public and private
derision from them.
But what we did that was maybe
even more important--
only 3 million are in the field,
that's not every kid--
is change the agenda for
every minister of
education on the planet.
The job of the minister of
education is to educate the
kids of their country, it's
the job of the country.
And if you're living in a
developing world country, and
I won't name the country, but a
large country in Africa, for
example, a third of the teachers
that are paid to show
up, don't show up, the next
third are literate.
You're doing with one third of
the teachers that actually
show up, try to do right
by the kids,
and know how to read.
At that point, better
teacher training
doesn't solve the problem.
You just realize the
kids are smart.
When you want to fix, maybe
not a Google, but normal
everyday people, when they want
to fix an electronics
problem, they hand it
to a kid, right?
Because kids, they're sponges,
they figure it out.
By definition, one or two of us
in every 100 are geniuses.
By definition, we
say that, right?
They're going to
figure it out.
And the situation is so bad in
so much of the developing
world you have to leverage
the kids themselves.
So sure, computers are also
being used in the classroom,
Khan Academy, all this great
stuff that's happening
everywhere.
But we were focused
on the developing
world for that program.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: That's the only
question we have on the
Google Moderator.
JEAN WANG: Actually, I do have
a follow-up question to that,
is how do you take the feedback
that you get on OLPC,
for example, and how do you roll
that into the next design
or improvements?
MARY LOU JEPSEN: I think a lot
of the feedback that OLPC got,
and I haven't been with
the organization
now for four years.
But a lot of the feedback
they got was on, what
do the tests show?
And there was a lot of testing,
particularly in
Uruguay and Peru, where there
were very large deployments.
Rwanda, Afghanistan, Pakistan
had bigger deployments as I
understand it.
And some of the feedback on the
testing was, sure, truancy
went down, community engagement
went up, kids were
online, but were their
test scores better?
In some cases they were better,
in some cases they
were about the same.
But the truth is I think OLPC
has been criticized for not
doing enough testing.
That said, I think literacy
rates in Peru there's like
these different levels
they measure.
I can't remember the
numbers of them.
But in villages, Peru went into
places that didn't have
electricity, or internet,
or anything
to deploy the laptops.
Sorry, something's beeping, I
don't know which one, probably
my cell phone.
In those places, there was like
90% of the kids couldn't
even pass to the sort of base
level, which, I think, there
was five, four, three,
two, one call it.
So there'd be nobody at level
one, nobody at level two,
maybe two kids at level
3, most of the kids at
level four and five.
And six months with a laptop, it
got to like 30% of the kids
were like in level two.
And so that was pretty
compelling.
But yeah, I think how OLPC has
reacted is sort of saying,
it's hard to say this, the
teachers are a critical part
of education.
So what do you do when the
teachers don't show up, or are
illiterate, or are scared
of the technology?
Can you make the technology easy
enough to use so the kids
can learn on their own
without the teachers?
And that's the grand experiment
that OLPC is now
doing with pretty rigorous
social scientists.
I think they've got three
different sort of great
thinkers on how we learn to
read and so forth in a
non-reading society.
I think there's been very little
significant research
done on how a culture
with absolutely no
reading goes to reading.
So they're studying that to say,
how do we get around this
problem of teachers
and schools?
It's radical.
It's only part of the program.
A lot of the program is dealing
in the infrastructure,
transforming a lot of schools
in Latin America.
But then, the big problems, as
I think one of the lead execs
at One Laptop per Child puts it,
the rich kids are the ones
that get to go to school.
There's 100, 200 million
kids that don't even
get to go to school.
How do you reach those kids?
So that sort of takes the
politics out of it.
They're not getting to go
to school, can we do
something by them?
Because their life opportunities
are extremely
limited if they don't ever learn
how to read, if they
don't get to go to school,
if they don't
get access to education.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: And they are
usually the group that's a
little bit more hungry
for knowledge.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Yeah, hungry
for opportunity, and feel
lucky, so they'll work
hard, when they can.
So that's a long-winded answer
to the question.
VIVIAN CROMWELL: I think
this is our wrap-up.
Thanks to Mary Lou for
joining us today.
And I think tomorrow there is
another Women Techmakers
episode around the same time.
So stay tuned and join us.
Thank you, guys.
JEAN WANG: Thank you.
Thanks to Mary.
MARY LOU JEPSEN: Thank you
two, Vivian and Jean.